ce week-end des événements comme la
journée du patrimoine ont été annulés en
revanche d'autres festivités ont pu se
dérouler normalement sur le cas par
exemple de la présentation de l'opéra
aïda de verdi au stade de france c'était
vendredi dernier
les musées sont également restés ouverts
et un complexe comme le futuroscope de
poitiers n'a connu finalement aucune
baisse de fréquentation christophe de
balan bras philippe ritaine le silence
envahit les files d'attentes du
futuroscope c'était à midi précise
vendredi dernier entre deux animations
les visiteurs se recueille en mémoire
des victimes mais aussi par solidarité
avec le peuple américain
ce soit dans un parc d'attraction en
action grâce à nous il faut forcément
c'est un minimum
en attendant mieux tu es bien
une fameuse représailles mais je pense
qu'on méritait celle là quelques jours
plus tard tout le monde a encore à
l'esprit l'horreur ressenti le jour des
attentats de 100 mo à la découverte des
premières images et la réflexion ensuite
je pense c'est la bêtise humaine
personnalisée de la bêtise humaine
vraiment c'est horrible horrible ça là
aujourd'hui une petite journée détente
c'est vraiment se dit bien vous redouter
les conséquences quelles conséquences
à la guerre comme cette jeune fille
chacun ici est conscient que l'amérique
est sur le pied de guerre
li à l'inquiétude d'un conflit
international mais il ya aussi la
volonté de ne pas céder à langoat de
continuer à vivre ce qu'on voit à la
télé ce qu'on voit sur les journaux
c'est son renvoi à chaque fois
à la même situation pour ça que vous
êtes venu aujourd'hui ici mais pour ce
pour se changer les idées et puis c'est
vrai qu'il faut pas devenir paranoïaque
par rapport à tout cela profite à tous
il faut prendre pour les séances on et à
mesure ici de leur offrir pendant une
journée ou deux journées un cadre
différent et qui peuvent un petit peu
oublié ce qui se passe à l'extérieur ça
sans pour autant se désengager bien
évidemment alors ici pas de mesures de
sécurité particulières tout juste une
vigilance accrue des agents de
surveillance
le parc du futuroscope et ses visiteurs
ne veulent pas succomber à la terreur